Coca Cola can do some pretty strange things.
And the ingredients inside of it might be even more bizarre.
Just imagine what it's doing inside your body after you drink it.
Now, let's take that one step further and imagine only drinking
Coca-Cola for the rest of your life.
What affects does Coca Cola have on your body?
What would this do to your teeth and how
bad would replacing water with Coke?
Be this is what F and here's what would happen
if you only drank Coca Cola, believe it or not.
Someone has done something like this before a woman in Monaco
stopped drinking water and only drank Coca-Cola for
16 years straight.
Did she survive doing this to her body?
And what would happen if you did the same?
Doctors recommend that people shouldn't drink anywhere from three to four liters
of water a day. So instead, we're going to replace that with coconut Cola,
a single can of Coke has 39 grams of sugar to get
your daily fluid intake.
You'd need it to drink over eight cans of Coke each day,
that's 312 grams of sugar.
It would be like eating six chocolate bars for
reference.
It's recommended that people consume less than 40 grams of sugar every
day. So, yeah,
this would be a lot of extra sugar not to mention the extra
calories your coconut take alone would be nearly an
extra 8,000 calories a week,
but that wouldn't be all the extra calories. You'd find soon.
This sugary drink could also cause you to eat more as well.
And with all these extra calories,
it would lead to some serious weight gain.
As you drank more cope, tooth decay would also be a severe issue.
Each sip of Coke would cook your teeth,
tongue and gums for hours after you finished your soda,
unless you stuck to an incredibly strict toothbrushing schedule,
the sugars would slowly break down your enamel.
This could eventually lead to your teeth, completely rotting.
And once you're done drinking your sodas for the day,
expect to be going to the washroom a lot.
The caffeine and Coca-Cola is a natural diuretic,
meaning that you're going to be peeing a lot more,
but the caffeine would be the least of your worries.
One of the main ingredients you'd need to worry about is the high fructose
corn syrup. That's because our bodies don't metabolize it.
And this could lead to a fatty liver
dumps of a fatty liver include fatigue and pain in the upper right
abdomen. As you continued to drink Coca Cola,
you would experience even more health issues.
You might have frequent fainting spells and have a potassium deficiency
due to all the sugar, caffeine and other chemicals.
You'd also experienced problems with your heart rate,
but the issues won't stop there as time goes on.
You'd also have a massive risk of getting type two diabetes
and loads of vitamin deficiencies.
And if all these issues continued and you decided to ignore them,
you could develop proteinuria, which could then lead to kidney problems.
And after years of only drinking Coke,
you'd eventually be 600 pounds with a huge list of health
issues.
You'd take your final sips of Coca-Cola and then die due to a heart
attack, kidney failure or other health-related issues.
But it doesn't have to be like that.
Remember the woman who drank Coca-Cola for 16 years,
she had a lot of the same issues you had with fainting and weight gain.
But after 16 years of only drinking Coke,
she decided to stop.
And her body bounced back to a relatively healthy state in a short period of
time.
So you might be able to do this for over a decade without experiencing any
severe repercussions,
but although drinking only Coke for a week a month or
even a year, wouldn't kill you. It doesn't mean you should do it.
Another thing you shouldn't do jump out of an airplane without a parachute,
but luckily with our new show, how to survive,
we'll show you the perfect way to make sure you get out of it alive.